now I want to find out how long that
interval is a B how are we going to do
it when someone has a genious suggestion
or something maybe I can add on so we're
gonna probably make you in an hour
okay great I can use Pythagoras er
that's true I'm a little mystified as to
how because Pythagoras's theorem
required a not just any training our a
wide angle finder I don't see any x on
this so where are you going to put one
one okay where am I going to draw it
I can draw lots of triangles on here but
so much effort it's wet oh okay
muttering take Jake suggestion
Jake's auditioning I'm going to go down
from being like this and I need
something else and then across okay I'm
going to Chandra mangai go to the left
okay now we've dotted lines you can see
I've got all the way the reason why this
is helpful is because if I go all the
way to we call designs with coordinate
axes if you remember I go all the way
the axes will help me work out the
length that I have here right so now I'm
going to complete that triangle just
kind of imply
and what you saw that is as we noticed
before with 1.0 theorem you're going to
need a wire language 1 so why do you
check that bilingual in there ok now
we're going to find the hypotenuse
that's a B but to get to the hypotenuse
I need the other two lates let's just
have a look at the vertical one because
someone tell me what that vertical like
this hey how do I follow thanks a lot
it looks to me like all right you've
constructed it I asked you to construct
a DC diagram this one have a look
stay with me the question then becomes
which link we have to work yes ultimate
triangle I don't have this one unity on
bottom right so this one here is for but
the reason I know it's for it because it
for five take white one yeah now by the
way and like which one yes
actually this is really important that's
the question I wanna ask why is it right
a Kuwaitis be what he comes come from
right because that what a point dog and
then what have a point dog okay so I
multiply it just a little bit it's when
the interval starts and then in the end
like to see that it comes all way from
five down to one so the length of the
intro is the difference okay that's why
it's five take away one tell me what the
length is that one
looks like to wait is to come from
Daniel in the hundred and four people
tour along but then so that so their
business - yeah follow you yeah so this
is for take way to which is also to yeah
alright now we're ready what we can now
write is in this triangle Rotella I can
do Chi Chi versus fear right so I can
say a B squared equals what anyone's my
Tigers together in a squared plus B
squared my pieces the hypotenuse cool so
I'm going to go four squared plus two
squared you agree as Pythagoras so
therefore since the skydivers I'm going
to say as I disappear I'm trying to
demonstrate where this comes from so
right now yes we'll get onto that enemy
[Music]
now I'm going to just compute this a
little bit magnetizer
4 squared is 16 2 squared is 4 so I'm
getting a 2000 okay and now I'm ready to
find out what ideas is the
okay now I'm almost finished
Andrew thank you always finished I do
want to point out I just asked you to
find the distance so I haven't asked you
to approximate however some of you may
have reached your calculator and
approximated before you do it for you do
it
$20 wait number what's this planner but
it's smaller than that 16 and the square
number above it is 25 steps 4 squared +
5 squared this is like between 4 & 5 do
you agree
thinking four and maybe four point or
something like that means this older
jacket four point four seven - not bad
okay now this is no length so I need to
supply some units with it that is no
certainty as medias donated or anything
so all you have to say is units and the
reason why I've checked at our four
point seven ish website 4.4 says wasn't
all right it's just how I can think is
that a reasonable number which it sure
is that's 4 and a 2 should be a little
bit older over this okay now here's what
you do remember when we did this
question to start with
right this is a bit stickier because
you've got points and they cross
different quadrants you've got negative
numbers in there okay I'm going to give
you a minute to try and work out so the
first question we did today can you
attach assistance page choose now you're
on the same idea here construct the
triangle work out the lights carefully
and then care for have a shot okay has
you got an answer
does the degree of mine all right put
your pens down for a minute I need to
know finish it's okay I won't rub it
edges off so if you only touch off the
tent heads down things down full
attention because I'm always raised it
keeps going
there's our solution and you can see on
my working there I have forgotten to say
the reason for the first line so I'm
just going to add that now now I just
want to draw your attention to my
diagram and if you drew the diagram like
I asked you before I know it's a bit
lost but still good enough to be able to
demonstrate this I want you to look at
the similarities and differences between
this diagram and this one over here
we've started just lifes and it lived
inside one quadrant there were no
negatives ok fascitis consol sharpie
what's some similar things you see
between diagram one diagram - anything
to be said again last night
ahead for starters right angle triangle
right do you know is like an old
Pythagoras why are we making such a big
deal like this reason wise even when
they're very binary trainees to begin
with you can make right angle trainers
almost anywhere ok so you see that
whilst you sit it's in common
what's they are look at vertical length
of the triangle for the height I should
say that's the high of training hey hey
right do you notice how and if you
haven't written down you should how did
I find out that it was eight now I did
it in exactly the same way I did this
before you've got the top one you take
away the bottom one do you agree he runs
up I've got the top one that's up at
three and I've taken away the bottom
line but look the bottom line is
negative you notice that that's why
three take away maybe five that gives
you the full eight does that make sense
and to say to you okay now are you
feeling it's a bit of a drag right every
single time that approach is persist for
a triangle in both Pythagoras theorem
etc that's why we say if we want to get
to this I don't like to call it formula
I like to call the shorter that's what
it is
you deserve that bigger bit later and
then I out of here
I'd like it right now distance equals
okay so dinars there's a big square root
sign over the top where is the spirit
come from why the distance or get habits
where we did because Pythagoras had
squared unit and you want to undo part
of it now you don't want C squared you
just want see that make sense so that's
why is a big long square root I'm
underneath here there are two beings two
squares being added why are the two
squares being added
because in Pythagoras's theorem right
that's how the first line begins that
Carol the structure is there it's from
Pentos not just by accident and then
inside the thing is being squared I'm
going to write it like this but mommy to
follow thanks x2 minus x1 y2 minus 1 why
are there things being subtracted in
there what's going on why for instance
why is it not X 2 plus X 1 Y the X 2
minus
exclusive an insurance I'm trying to
find like what interesting represent the
shorter this one represents this suicide
over here and this one represents that
shorter side right you've got to take
the differences see how that's a
difference and that's the difference if
I actually wanted that like you said
five six one that wouldn't make sense
right you're subtracting your gain the
difference this is how you remember
where the pluses and minuses are would
have plotted in there cuz I ran ads
science speaks where and the -
engineering here because you're trying
to find the distance between those